should we get offensive should we should
we anger all the feminists
oh are you are you prepared to make
feminists angry okay what do we do in
here
all right let's go so i got this uh this
is actually fairly old this is from zach
goldberg he's a great data researcher
and journalist on twitter
and he tweeted this uh uh he says
overall with one exception white
moderates those in the 18 to 29 age
group are more likely to report being
diagnosed with a mental health condition
the differences among white liberals
though are striking
almost half of white liberals in this
cohort
report a diagnosis and in this graph he
shows us
four different age groups 18 to 29 30 to
49 50 64 and 65 plus
65 plus from liberal moderate to
conservative low instances of mental
health
uh i'm sorry mental health conditions
low instances of mental health no no
the opposite you don't have any this is
amazing
among 18 to 29 year old white liberals
45.9 mental illness
white conservatives 20.9 less than half
this is amazing even among the 65 and up
the white liberals are overwhelmingly
more
mentally ill than moderates and
conservatives
now we're gonna offend the feminists
let's break down
white let's well let's let's let's break
down a little bit these demographics
because zac
goldberg gives us another one he says
some of you asked for it so here is the
last chart broken down by
gender the biggest gap with age x
ideological group is between white
liberal men and women
in the 18 to 29 category that's right
white liberal women between the ages of
18 to 29 have a 56.3
instance of being diagnosed with a
mental health condition white liberal
men
33.6 among 30 to 49 year olds
white liberals women 39.7 men 29.7
and it's very very similar but even
among white conservative women
27.3 in the 18-29
age bracket now the first thing i'll say
is i think the age thing shows us
a generational shift in mental health
diagnosis
someone who is 65 probably was not
diagnosed with things
diagnosed with conditions when they were
young another older don't care to go to
the doctor and actually get diagnosed
with this
the difference the important factor is
the gap
among white liberals 65 and older it's
almost identical
15.2 to 15 percent men white liberal men
and women 65 or older
have similar instances of mental health
issues so there is something creating a
a massive gap between white liberal
gen z millennials and i think
i think i know what it might be what is
it not having families yep
not having relationships not necessarily
families not necessarily kids
but no relationships and i particularly
think no kids
and i wonder if and you can give me your
opinion and lydia as well because
you're the ladies in the room we've had
other people on the show say that
the reason women are are unwell and
unhappy and depressed is because they're
not having children
what do you think julie yeah what do you
think not maybe
uh sorry i hope you don't mind me asking
were you ever like super depressed did
you find this to be an issue for you
before you had your kid
i actually got a lot of anxiety after oh
anxiety yeah um
oh gosh yeah i think with older people
i think there's was just a stigma
against
reaching out and getting therapy and all
that
with the younger people i feel like
being a liberal would be so
hard because if you don't have kids like
you you were talking about you're
focused on all this other stuff
and a lot of stuff is just out of your
control
like the liberals are very focused on
like climate change issues i know that's
a huge one with them having climate
change anxiety and just
you know all this racism and stuff and
they're it's it's out of your control
where i think conservative people are
kind of more focused
in words and on the individual and on
their families where liberals is like i
want to save the world world
peace and it's like no there's ukrainian
crimea and all this stuff and you can't
do anything on an individual level about
that
that is such a good point because you're
right conservatives do focus
on the individual level and that means
they do things like make families
they have kids they focus on their work
they find things to do that are
meaningful
and they don't tend to stress too much
about stuff that they cannot have
any possible control over like global
warming when it comes to the older
people
a lot of them probably did struggle with
this stuff and they probably just
learned
to live with it or yeah hush hush
don't suck it up you're right yeah
you're destroying the family
yeah keep it together yeah but then like
the whole family thing i definitely
think that the fact that women aren't
having children is incredibly depressing
to them
i just want to throw my two cents in
there because i think that's probably
one of the biggest problems that we face
you know the meme about you guys ever
watch archer
yeah oh yeah i love the show no i don't
think i was
more i'm just not intelligent enough
it's not a smart show trust me i just
played games video games
there was that episode where um it's
been a long time since i watched archer
i just rewatched it what's
what's the name of the alana is that her
name uh
lana lana archer keeps calling her baby
crazy
yes and it's funny she is but it's like
there's a joke
that very much resonates with i think i
think 30 rock did this
this joke tv shows and culture has have
made jokes about women
whose biological clocks are ticking and
how they want to have kids
men don't experience that i'm wondering
if that
plays a role in why there's a gap
between men and women like a biological
difference
it does for me i'm not in a rush to have
kids and if i was i'd be in a
a completely different person my goals
and my
behavior would be completely that's like
that's dudes yeah
yeah i can have kids when i'm 80. that's
a privilege yeah it's not as easy but
you can
they found that men also lose fertility
i mean
later than women but like 40s and 50s
and there's
more of a chance of having a problem
with the child it's true
i don't want to destroy the male ego
here no no no it it it is
it is true but the issue is that women
yeah if a guy's firing off several
million
yeah if 90 of those are just
deficient he's got a couple that are
working no you got like millions
right all right so what happens is that
you'll end up seeing you know older guys
have kids
you know and for women it's a lot
different you know i i know it's like
the craziest thing that this is an
offensive topic but it is like feminists
whenever i talk about this kind of stuff
it's like all the feminists start
lighting me up on twitter they're all
angry and i'm like
is it is it wrong to point out that
they're they're advising women to freeze
their eggs
i mean do your thing man more power to
you it really
works freezing eggs i think we're kind
of lying to women saying you know
there are instances of 40 year old women
having birth but
they're rare do you really want to take
that risk
probably not if you really want kids so
think about this right we're talking
about mental illness i i don't want to
act like i am saying this is the sole
reason people experience mental illness
but i'm saying i believe there's a huge
factor in the fact that
as a 35 year old guy with no kids i
should probably start thinking about
having a family but i got it
yeah whatever i'm a superb is okay but
but are you energetic enough for
kids if you're 40 50 60 baby
years old because you saw my son he was
jumping up and down on those feed bags
i got energy for days oh he does it too
yeah oh yeah he's got this yeah i think
i'm a crazy person
but the point is i don't have to
consider
a biological limitation if you were a 35
year old woman you definitely would
so i'm wondering if there are women who
are sitting here and and you guys tell
me what you think
when they're looking at the media saying
just freeze your eggs and work and be a
ceo and they're thinking themselves but
i
want to have kids too and you've got a
combination of mainstream liberal social
stigma telling you
no you can't take time off and the
physical realities of
you might have to you could be a ceo
later in life
though like your kids are so young for
such a short amount of time
like i'm 32 i have the rest of
my life to work i can be 40 50 years old
my mom is a stay-at-home mom she's still
working
so she got it all women you know there's
also the thing that women can have it
all like
no you can't you can't have it all at
the same time exactly thank you okay
yeah i think we have it backwards and i
do think that you have a point because
i've known so many great and amazing
women who went and they raised their
kids
they got them like up into high school
they sent them off and they're like and
then they went back to school a lot of
them became
nurses some of them became teachers and
pharmacists and stuff i was like that
seems like such a good balance because
if you want to work
by the time you're that age you'll know
exactly what you want to do your kids
will have a firm start in life and
you'll be able to go
yeah and you can have it like your
career in your head at the same time
you're not
worrying about i'm 35 40 years old i
might have to get ivf which is really
expensive
right you mentioned your kids are really
young for a short amount of time
reminds me of this really funny story
this guy posted on the internet he was
like 25
and he went and visited his dad or it's
like he was at his parents house for the
holidays and out of nowhere his dad
walks in the room and just
grabs him and lifts him up as high as he
could and he's like dad what are you
doing
and his dad said i saw a meme where it
said one day
you care you lifted your child for the
last time and didn't realize it
and then they both started laughing like
his dad was basically like i can pick my
son up whenever i want
but but no that's it's an interesting
point too like the people don't realize
that
you pick your kid up one day the next
day you don't and then that may have
been the last time you never noticed
there's gonna be a last time
and then so that dad walks in he's like
picking up his 25 year old man of his
son
you know i love it that's cute do you
guys think that there's like resentment
between women and men
the women resenting the men their age
that don't want to have kids and don't
have to
and the women are like but i i feel
guilty for resenting them because they
don't they shouldn't have to
and they're not biologically bound so
why would they but then they're
internalizing this resentment
and lashing out against men i think
there's some women who do
but i think there's some men who do you
know what i mean
my bigger concern is not like the
individual it's the it's what we're
encouraging and exacerbating in culture
i would ask that because i think i have
some deep resentment against women that
want to have
kids with me at my age because
they they are on a time clock i'm not
and i know they are and i shouldn't
it's hard to feel the pressure yeah well
i think that's why
you more often see a younger woman an
older man i think it kind of makes sense
the men at a later age are more
financially stable or
more mature and they're better able to
raise a child where the
younger woman is both more fertile
okay so i think that that combination
makes more sense so i would say
you know if you're a young 20 something
year old girl
probably don't date guys that are in
their young 20s because most of them
you know they don't want to have kids
right now they don't have to
maybe go a decade up or so that's just
my opinion
and now here's here's the the really
offensive part for the feminists
the kind of person who's going to be
writing an article
consistently or writing articles
consistently
is not likely to be you know a
stay-at-home mom who's got
kids and and dealing with them you you
tend to see the careerist feminists
who are in these positions at media
outlets with the time and energy
to write these articles so their
perspective is that
of one type of person right oh yeah
yeah as a stay-at-home mom you don't
really have as powerful as a voice i
would say
right definitely it's really fascinating
to see all these these feminist writers
and and it's no surprise then that many
of the
the women who work in digital media are
feminists because
you know they don't want to have
families they want a career and they
want to fight for that
that's their opinion that's why they're
there or one of the reasons and they're
going to write those opinions over and
over and over again
then it's interesting because i wonder
how that affects other women who know
it's like hey i want to have a kid
before this age
but everything you read from every woman
in a high-profile media position
is saying don't have kids freeze your
eggs i was thinking
if my mom had focused all the energy she
focused on me and my brothers
into the world it would have been very
bad for the world
because she was very neurotic not in a
harmful way but
neuroticism as a personality trait uh
overly
just micromanaging and wanting
everything to be perfect and for me to
not be
exposed to the wrong thing and like if
she had been doing that to other people
i think that would have been devastating
so i see your point
interesting point i don't know these
people are blogging as opposed to
treating well so
you when i when i look at this chart
from zach goldberg and you can see that
consistently there's a gap between men
and women
except for moderates between 50 and 64
men are more likely to
this is this is fascinating check this
out among white moderates
men are more likely to have been
diagnosed with mental illness by about
one percentage point
you want to know what i think that might
be 50 to 64 years old
divorce no what war veterans
oh yeah vietnam korea maybe yeah
yeah even iraq at this point the first
around the world
yeah that was way more brutal than we
heard about in the news 20 years ago
some of these guys might have been 30
years old
and they might have been a career have
had a career in the military and now
they're getting deployed and they've so
they've seen some stuff
but that's only one group it's only
moderates i mean among liberals it's not
there among conservatives it's still
women
yeah but but but i i wonder why is it
and no matter what you say you're gonna
get you're gonna offend somebody that
women consistently report having more
mental health conditions
it's because women are more willing to
go to the doctor
yeah yeah probably or is it because men
are big and strong
and and yeah yeah they don't need to
they're going to get me down depression
i'll punch it out of myself i'll just
forget about it
guy wakes up he's like i'm depressed
today so he punches himself in the face
he's like no i'm not
that works right i'm pretty sure that
would be a mental illness
women are maybe should go to the doctor
yeah i think uh you know seeing a
therapist admitting you have a problem
is seen as a weakness
uh to men i don't want to i don't want
to acknowledge my own
neuroses who does i feel stupid when i
do that and i feel like i'm
creating it when it wasn't there i think
for me it's more uh i'm too arrogant
not in that i'm like no one's going to
tell me i'm weak it's it's kind of like
no i self-analyze
and i self-uh diagnose and then i try to
assess
and solve any you know things that i see
in myself
so when i'm feeling depressed when i'm
anxious when i'm angry
i kind of you know question and think
about it and try and figure out what's
conducive to a positive working
environment or to my goals
and if this thing i'm feeling isn't
doing that then i need to navigate that
myself
and i do and it works for me thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you